qu'il Viva Berlin Beyrout Tokyo Istanbul
impossible pour eux de rester les bras
croisés tous sont descendus dans les
rues pour dire non à l'invasion russe
contre l'occupation russe de l'Ukraine
tout comme nous avons protesté contre
l'intervention rues en Syrie et en
Crimée liberté au peuple mort aux
empires voici le message de cette
banderole déployée place de la
République où se sont masser des
centaines de personnes plutôt dans la
journée une autre manifestation avait
déjà eu lieu à Paris devant l'ambassade
de Russie avec dans ses rangs des
candidats à la présidentielle mais
surtout de nombreux Ukrainiens expatriés
pour eux se rassembler est aussi un
moyen de conjurer l'angoisse
ce matin en me levant et en voyant les
tout ce qui se passe c'était c'était un
chèque pour nous parce qu'on a toute la
famille là-bas j'ai mes neveux et son
petit là où j'habite il y a eu des
bombardements
les protestations se propagent aux
quatre coins du globe y compris chez le
belligérant dans plus d'une cinquantaine
de villes russes certains n'hésitent pas
à braver la répression pour s'opposer
Rav Vladimir Poutine
il doit arrêter la guerre qu'est-ce
qu'on doit faire je ne sais pas la seule
chose qu'on peut faire c'est de dire
qu'on n'est pas d'accord la réaction des
autorités russes ne s'est pas fait
attendre en début de soirée plus de 1400
manifestants avaient déjà été arrêté
selon une ONG de lutte contre les
persécutions politiques en Russie